new in theaters this weekend night
school and small foot what will you see
this is your weekend ticket bummed out
by the increase in morning traffic now
that schools back in session
we'll check out night school Tiffany
Haddish and Kevin Hart team up in this
hilarious comedy about a guy who blows
up the store he works in and is then
forced to return to night school to earn
his GED Tiffany and Kevin Hart aren't
enough for you with the square root of
81 what what's the square root of 81 I
don't know well you're in luck how about
we throw in taran killam a Rob Riggle
and a Ben Schwartz this movie is for you
if you enjoy laughing you always wanted
to go back to school but you don't
actually want to go back to school and
would rather watch Kevin Hart do it for
you or you have a notebook full of
Tiffany Haddish his name but instead of
her last name it's your last name you
know just to see what it sounds like
anonymous yeah also in theaters oh I
don't know the truth the small foot does
exist here's your proof oh my gosh fun
for the entire family small foot is an
animated adventure story by Warner
animation group depicting the legend of
a Yeti but from yetis perspective
nestled high in the mountains amigo a
member of the big-footed Getty community
discovers a human
a small foot and must prove to his peers
that he's telling the truth I know how
it feels this movie is for you if you're
looking for a solid family outing you're
ready for it to be winner already or if
you're a fan of x-files unlike agent
Mulder you know the truth is out there
that is your weekend ticket what do you
think is the most real the Yeti Bigfoot
or my chances with Tiffany Haddish and
check back next week to see Tom Hardy
join the Marvel family
[Music]
you